hey everybody could to be here I gave a
talk here at one of the meetups like six
years ago seven years ago was one of the
highlights of my career so it's good to
be back this talk is called forecasting
at scale and it's kind of like a little
bit of a joke like a bad joke because at
scale doesn't mean like you know
everyone's like Facebook you got a lot
of data so like the hard problem is how
do you work with all that data like here
the scale is actually like people and
problems so that's kind of like what I
want to focus on and it's really
exciting to be able to talk about we
released this open-source package profit
about a year ago and it's really
exciting to like see it take off in the
community and get all the support so
it's fun to be able to tell you guys the
story about how we built it so I have
the kind of like the acquired the
illness of being trained as an economist
so I think about things a lot in like
supply and demand frameworks even though
I'm kind of a data scientist now and
when I think about projects and problems
at Facebook I think about demand for
solutions so there's tons of different
Kocher on facebook basically like
acquiring problems and trying to figure
out like how we can what the what the
total demand is for like say a problem
like forecasting so for forecasting
there's a bunch of different reasons why
people will demand forecast like they
need to do capacity planning so one of
the biggest forecasters of Facebook is
the infrastructure team which needs to
know like how many servers to servers to
buy how many data centers to build every
goal at Facebook is set with respect to
like a forecast of some kind so you
can't just say like I'm gonna make this
thing go up by 10 percent because it
might have gone up by 10 percent even if
you sat on your ass so people always
make their you know have to make a
forecast and then we make a goal with
respect to the forecast and you can also
use forecast to do anomaly detection and
homilies are really important when you
have a big company that's hard to kind
of like see what what's going on in
aggregate so when you when you find
anomalies you can respond to them but
you can otherwise assume things are
going pretty well and also like there's
just like lots of applications for
forecast that we haven't thought of yet
so the problem is that like even once
you have one of these applications
pinned down like the number of forecasts
that you have to make really multiplies
like you end up having to make a lot of
forecasts and that's like one of the
reasons why we have this like scale
problem we have them forecast many
different quantities for many different
units so we might want to forecast for
every country we want to forecast for
every platform or device type so there's
just like lots of different variants or
units of forecast that we want to make
and then we have this problem we're like
not many
people are actually experts at
forecasting so time series trainings
like pretty pretty unusual like not many
people have like a lot of experience
making forecasts so this is like a real
problem because we need we need to be
there's this huge demand and we have to
meet it with some supply and there's no
real like off-the-shelf tools that are
gonna solve this problem unlike for like
a lot of other machine learning problems
like we've seen today so here's the
supply and demand curve you're gonna
have like your micro economic theory
nightmares but here's here's the way
that I mentally think about this maybe
this is instructive for you maybe not on
the on the x-axis we have like quantity
of forecasts and on the y-axis we have
like the price of a forecast but the
price of forecast really is like how
long does it take you to make it and
make it to the quality that like that is
acceptable and then we have the supply
curve which is like how we can supply
forecasts and and when I think about
projects I always pitch this idea of
like there's a there's a demand
hypothesis and a supply hypothesis the
demand I bought this is like what the
shape of this curve is like if we made
forecast easier like how many more
forecast would people do like would it
really solve a lot of problems for
people and then there's the supply
hypothesis like how far could we shift
that supply curve by improving how
people do forecasts and if you can if
both of those things are all far off to
the right then you generate a lot of
value you unlock a lot of value by
shifting the supply curve if the demand
curve is more shallow then maybe
shifting the supply curve is and isn't
it's great or if you can't really shift
the supply curve by like making forecast
a lot easier then you don't get a lot of
value either but you really want both of
those things to be true at the same time
so we need to figure out a way to shift
that supply curve and the answer was to
like automate forecasting as best we
could the reason why we had to automate
it was that people don't like have a lot
of time series training this is a stack
of a plot of Stack Overflow tags for
questions with different topics and you
can see like everybody's interested in
machine learning they want to build
classifiers they want to build
regression models but time series models
are like not sexy at all like no one's
no one's working on them and in fact
like they're probably among the most
boring statistics classes that you could
possibly take so I don't blame people
for not really wanting to do this and so
we're just not going to be able to meet
the supply or meet the demand for
forecast with a supply of like people
like we're gonna have to figure out a
way to like make it easier to get more
forecast
per person so the solution the supply
curve shift that I'm gonna like that we
worked on was can we like come up with
some way to automate or at least semi
automate make it cheaper for people to
produce forecasts and the key
ingredients there basically that like
find similarities across forecast
problems so they're all kind of
different but maybe there's something
similar about them that would that would
suggest that the same approach could
work try to build a tool that will solve
most of them maybe not all of them like
we're aiming for like an 80/20 rule kind
of thing here so maybe with 20% of the
work we can solve 80% of the problems
make it easy to use and teach people to
use it so we need to democratize this
tool we need to get it in people's hands
but make it like intuitive for them to
use and then finally we can't just have
people sort of like have a black box
that like gets them an answer but then
they can't make any modifications to it
forecasting is a is a field where are
you injecting your domain knowledge into
the problem can really pay off in a lot
of ways so we want to give people the
ability to like not just get blocked
when they get an answer and say like
there's no way forward I think of this
often is like you know when you build a
classifier and your classifier kind of
sucks you have like somewhere to go from
there oh I need new features or any new
data load forecasting problem you get a
shitty forecast you're like I don't know
what to do next we wanted to give people
a path forward so that was this is this
is a sketch of the solution that we came
up with so here's a motivating time
series this is sort of like you know I'm
gonna show you like my technique works
on the thing that it was designed to
work on so it's not gonna like prove
that much but this is sort of like what
we were what we were aiming the kind of
time series we were aiming to forecast
when we started working on profit this
is the number of Facebook events that
are created per day and anybody see any
sort of like just call it out anything
repeatable about this work at about this
time series like why would we be able to
forecast any notable features
seasonality is there a trend kind of
there's outliers why is it spread out
like that weekday effects yes so we have
like holidays we have seasonality we
have yearly seasonality and weekday
seasonality and then we have like these
kind of like trend changes and that's
the rough shape of the time series that
we're trying to address but it fits a
large quantity of time series in my
experience especially at Facebook
so here's what happens this is like in
the infomercials when they show here's
what happens if you use the other guy's
product and someone's like really
ineptly like like burning yourself on a
frying pan trying to make an egg okay
this is if you use the forecast library
which is a wonderful library and Rob
Heineman has been like super helpful and
helping us make profit better so I want
to give him a ton of credit for like
having done a lot of the foundational
work and forecasting and he's got two
automated methods in his in his library
one is auto ARIMA and one is exponential
smoothing and they both perform a model
selection process so they're really
trying to like do a lot of work for you
and take a lot of this like time series
black magic out of the process for you
but you would get these like really
crappy forecasts if you had used those
methods on this time series out of the
box and of course like there's ways to
fix these forecasts up and Rob hyneman's
blog is like like it has like a litany
of questions about how to do this and
make it better and it's like we just
can't expect every everybody who's
running forecasts of Facebook to be able
to do all that research to figure out
how to get these things to work and then
like with regard to like intuitiveness
or interpretability
here's what happens if you went to like
help otto Rima you'd really be saying
how or EEMA because like because these
aren't really like intuitive answers to
your questions about how to make your
forecast better you'd be like maybe I
need to change this max Peter which is
the maximum value of P and like that's
it
like it doesn't really help you like or
give you like a path forward to making a
better forecast so your so people would
get really blocked they say like this
forecast package sounds great but it
doesn't work and then they don't know
what to do next so here's all the stuff
that we just talked about there's a
yearly cycle got this weekday
seasonality we have this yearly cycle
then we've got these sort of like spiky
seasonality period so we call those like
holidays or events those happen a lot in
Facebook data so like you know like the
Superbowl is a big event
it doesn't really correspond to like
it's not on the same day of the year
every year but it does happened and in
it and it is very important so like
things like that need to be accounted
for and then we have these outliers
outliers are like dates maybe the
logging broke or like double logged
things or like everybody's got and least
in my world like pretty low quality data
so your forecasting method should be
robust to these things and try to like
capture as much of this as possible but
try to like ignore the stuff that's not
that useful and another thing that's not
pictured here that profit I think does
pretty well with is like that like a lot
of data could be missing and the method
that we propose like doesn't worry about
missing data in any way so it'll like
it'll just sort of like neatly
interpolate over anything you're
anything that you're missing which is
kind of like another common property of
the data that we work with so how do we
model this so like if you're a time
serious person you're gonna sit down and
say like I need to model the generative
process of how this time series was
would be created in some hypothetical
world so and that turns out to be like
really hard thing to write down a
generative model for time series
processes like at each state like a new
thing is gonna happen and it's gonna
depend on the past in some way these
recursive models of time series and we
were like screw that we're not doing
that we're just gonna build a
discriminative model we are gonna fit
curves and it turns out to be a really
fruitful way forward so profit is
actually a simple decomposable time
series model it's a generalized additive
model so each component is additive but
the individual components may or may not
be linear so the first component is a
piecewise trend that can be either a
logistic trend or a linear trend and
that's going to account for basically
like how fast the time series is growing
or declining the second component is
going to be seasonality so that's going
to be like something that happens
regularly in cycles that recurs and we
can have multiple kinds of C
Alley and that's not a problem because
it's a generalized additive model we can
just add new components and then there's
gonna be this Holliday effect so these
are things that are spiky so there's
smooth things that change over time and
then they're spiky things that kind of
recur and then that's basically like all
you need to be able to extrapolate
something then finally there's this like
iid noise which is like anybody who's
studied time-series methods is like
rolling their eyes because this is like
the worst assumption because every time
series class would focus on modeling
this noise component would say like how
does the noise evolve over time and what
we're doing is saying like hey let's
model all that other stuff and like try
to whiten the noise as much as we can so
that like you know we don't have to
worry about the stuff that the normal
time series people spend like you know
500 beige books trying to characterize
okay so we have a couple tricks we use
l1 regular eyes trend chips in the first
component we use Fourier series for the
second component for the seasonality
component and then we just use dummy
variables for the holiday effects so
there's just like three little tricks to
profit it's not a fancy model I'm not
claiming like I invented something like
groundbreaking here but it works pretty
well so here's what the profit forecast
looks like for that time series that I
just showed you so this is me showing
you like if you fry an egg with my thing
you will not burn your hand and you'll
get a really beautiful looking egg and
of course this is like the time series
that it was designed for but it performs
well on a lot of other cases and I've
got a lot of feedback from people from
all kinds of different companies who are
using it really effectively so it turns
out that this it's a very biased model
like it's biased toward the kinds of
problems that we have but those problems
tend to recur in the wild a lot like
business time series data tends to have
this like human scale seasonality to it
like people just do things at certain
times a day or certain times of the year
and like and it's repeatable and it's
kind of predictable and that's really
what you want to capture and if you
capture that well then you can capture
the trends really well I'm not gonna
take questions I only have eight minutes
so I'm like all right so what's nice
about an additive model is that it has
components that we can explain so I can
tell somebody why the forecast was the
way that it was so here I'm explaining
the model that I just showed you it's
got a like a piecewise linear trend so
the trend sort of sort of the clients
for a little while then starts to
increase so this is like part of the
magic of profit is learning that like
there's this like local trend change
that now we're going to extrapolate from
there only then we've got our week
cycle so that's showing people mostly
create events on on Mondays but not on
the weekends because they're mostly like
attending those events on the weekends
and then we get this yearly cycle which
captures like what we were we were
visualizing the data we could say like
hey there was this dip during the summer
this dip at the end of the year the
early cycles taking care of that how do
we do that piecewise linear trend or the
piecewise logistic or trend we have this
neat little magic where we we generate a
bunch of candidate change points like
points where we think that the data
might have could potentially have
changed its trajectory and then we put a
little Blas prior on which is like a
sparse prior it's going to assume most
of the time that those change points are
zero but some of the time we're gonna
allow it to change so the data is going
to allow us to like basically the data's
gonna tell us when the time series has
shifted its trajectory which is a really
like nice feature so we're learning from
the data like how to extrapolate locally
from the end by kind of modeling the
past data as much as we can
so you can see here here's the posterior
Laplace distribution of blas parameters
that we've drawn for the time series and
you see that big trend shift at the end
so a predict time what we want to do is
like sample from those future trend
changes and what that's going to
basically do is say like a time series
that had lots of trend changes in the
past is going to have lots of trend
changes in the future that's going to
give it really wide confidence intervals
and a time series that have very few
trend changes in the past like a
straight line is just going to have a
very tight confidence intervals because
we think it's not likely to change in
the future so here's an example of what
the what the confidence intervals look
like from this procedure so they're not
actually like confidence intervals
because this isn't a generative model I
can't claim that they have any kind of
particular coverage properties but they
give you a rough sense of like how
uncertain you are about the future from
this time series which is really all
that a lot of business users want to
know they want to know like should I be
worried about this being like super
different in the future or can I be
relatively confident so one of the nice
things about profit is that we provide
lots of knobs and levers so this is the
idea here is that like I want to give
you a path forward after you finish your
forecast to like maybe make up make a
change to it and the reason this is
important is that humans have lots of
domain knowledge about the stuff that
they're modeling and they need to be
able to inject that domain knowledge
into the problem to get better results
and so we give people lots of ways to do
that and they're encoded because it's a
it's written down as as a model and
stand as a Bayesian model as
priors on parameters and so if you have
a strong prior that a parameter is close
to zero then it will like remove that
component from the model so we could say
like hey seasonality this this time
serious probably doesn't have your early
seasonality because it's like stock
market data so you can like turn that
turn that data down to that prior all
the way down to zero and then we'll say
like this parameter is probability 0 and
then the seasonality component just
shrinks out of the model so you get like
a knob there for that how often we
expect change points this will affect
like how Wiggly or how much we over fit
the insert the in sample data we have
functional forms for growth so you can
have like logistic growth or you can
have linear growth I think people have
been like in the github talking about
adding different kinds of growth
components they're all piecewise so they
sort of like our locally smooth and then
allowed to change at certain points but
otherwise like you can put any
functional form that you want then
there's covariance and holidays so we
allow people to model the data in
various ways if you have covariance that
are informative or if you know the dates
of certain holidays you can add those in
then you can have custom seasonality so
we we include weekly and yearly
seasonality by default and if you have
daily level data there will be daily
level seasonality but you could add your
own and then importantly we give people
the ability to say whether they want
just a map estimate so profit will fit
most time so you did in about a second
so you can get like a real interactive
workflow going but if you want to get a
full posterior over all the parameters
you can do that you just have to wait a
few minutes and then you get sort of
like full full estimate of uncertainty
so profit is just sort of like a general
answer to the question of like how do I
solve the problem of a lot of people
have a have a common problem that sort
of similar various ways and I need to
democratize a tool to solve that problem
and here's here's the basic playbook
that I think I've I this is this is what
I think plays out in practice a lot
you've probably built a lot of stuff
that looks like this a lot of our
packages look like this
you have your raw data which is like you
know what's in your database and you
spend some time standardizing it so that
it fits some input format so you saw in
Jared's talk like for to use XG boost
you have to make a matrix because that's
what it expects to see profit just
expects to see sort of like a sequence
of measurements over time with a
timestamp and so it has a pretty simple
input format then there's like your tool
is an abstraction layer over that
standardized data so it wraps it and
provides functionality on top of it like
an object so we can say like provide an
explanation for
what it found in the data it can provide
predictions or it can provide
Diagnostics about like how well it fit
or like why it fit the way that it did
and this is a really general playbook is
like you just forced your user to make
the data look a certain way and then you
provide all the functionality being
willing to assume that the data looks
the way that it does okay so what's the
process look like for building one of
these tools I think that this is this is
the rough playbook that we went through
with profit and I think I've seen this
play out a lot am I in my career at
Facebook it's like there's this rough
research process that goes on when
you're trying to build something like
this and it starts off with like a
hypothetical like could we even solve
this problem is it even possible and so
that's the basic research side then you
get to like something that you might be
able to use and then you build a
prototype and the prototype sucks and it
fails a lot and you work on that on that
phase for a really long time and I think
this is where like Stan came in really
handy as a tool because it allowed us to
get to a prototype really quickly and
iterate really quickly the prototype
phase is also where you want to gather
lots of use cases and try to make sure
that you do well on a number of them as
best you can
so that it's more general technique then
you shift to the quality code phase
we're like maybe someone at your company
who's a software engineer can use it so
we had a long phase of profit with
profit we're like the people who are
using it we're like the hardcore
software engineers at Facebook who were
willing to go through the hoops of like
how do I install this package why do I
have to install Stan and stuff like that
then finally we were able to like put
all the documentation together you know
write a lot of use cases and case
studies polish it up for external use
and that's where it became like a tool
like a quality something that like
people can use not just like experts and
I thought that was a really big like a
big step function change and like how
many people could use and benefit from
profit that's where the supply curve in
that economic diagram that I showed you
really shifted to the right so the
takeaways from this experience building
this tool or I think that like actually
the forecasting problem was not as such
a technical problem more of like a
people problem like we just needed to
figure out how to get a tool into
people's hands that address their needs
that gave them a path forward that you
know that was intuitive for them to use
and and that like wasn't didn't require
them to be time-series experts and then
we have lots of people that can move
forward on a problem like this profits a
super simple model it's not like rocket
science it's not like you know you don't
need the time
is expert to even develop this in the
first place like a lot of people could
have figured this out on their own the
simplicity of the method is actually a
virtue it means that when it fails it
fails in predictable ways that we
understand it's easy for people to
understand what it's doing and why it's
doing what it's doing and so like I
think that even though you might say hey
you didn't invent anything new I'll say
like yeah but it works well and like
people get it and so that's that's a
really nice virtue of a technique like
this and you can apply this playbook
over and over again and with the kind of
problems that show up at your company I
don't think that this is anything
particularly special about forecasting
there's lots of other statistical
problems that like you know you have to
just figure out what's common about them
and figure out what kind of tool and
what kind of interface will work for
most people so with that I'd like to
just sum up like you can try profit it's
open source you can download it you can
submit pull requests we'd love to see
those and we have paper about it that
summarizes a lot of the thoughts that I
just gave you like in a more verbose
form so please read that if you want to
thank you
thank you
you